- [Instructor] In this video
we're gonna take a deeper look
at the various producers and
consumers in an ecosystem.
And for the sake of
diversity, no pun intended,
we're gonna look at a marine ecosystem,
let's say an estuary.
And an estuary generally refers to a place
where you have a river coming
to where the tide comes.
So it's a mixture of both the
fresh water from the river
and the saltwater from the sea.
And they tend to be very
productive from an energetic,
or a biomass point of view.
So if I were to make an
energy pyramid for, let's say,
this estuary that we're
looking at right over here,
it might look something like this,
where at the bottom layer,
these are the primary producers,
and we've studied this in other videos.
Primary producers in a marine environment.
These would be things like phytoplankton.
Phyto, they're doing photosynthesis,
and they're plankton.
Plankton is a general term.
It comes from the Greek for drifter.
This right over here is sea grass.
Also something that can photosynthesize,
and this right over here is algae,
which I'm sure you have seen
when you've gone to the sea
or you've gone to a pond of some sort.
And when we think of photosynthesis,
we often talk about terrestrial things.
Things like trees, but a lot
of us don't realize that 50%,
that's a big number, of
Earth's photosynthesis,
or net primary production,
or organic energy compounds,
is produced by floating photosynthesizers,
like phytoplankton and ultraplankton.
So things like this, things
that you oftentimes don't see.
And as I mentioned, estuaries
tend to be quite productive.
They actually are comparable
to things like rainforests.
Now, for the sake of
making things tangible,
this being an estuary,
which is very productive,
let's imagine that the net
primary production from
this first layer, we can think
about it in terms of biomass,
maybe it's about 2,000 grams
per square meter per year.
Or we could think about
it in terms of calories.
This would be approximately equal to it.
It depends on the type of
biomass you're talking about,
but you have roughly four
kilocalories per gram.
So that would be roughly
8,000 kilocalories
per square meter per year.
That's the net primary
production of this first layer
of the primary producers.
Then what would we see at the next layer?
Well, we know that not all
of that energy can be used
by that next layer, which
would be the primary consumers.
And there's some examples here
and it's much more complex
than what this pyramid
depicts, but what we see here,
these are zooplankton, which are really,
you could view it as animal plankton.
It's a large category of things.
They have the word plankton in it.
So they kinda have to go with the flow
of whatever the tide is doing,
whatever the currents are doing.
Another primary consumer could be a fish
like this royal blue tang
that might be eating plankton,
and the net energy that's
available to the layer above that
is gonna be a small fraction
of the net primary productivity
of that first layer.
Typically it's about 10%.
So there might be,
instead of 8,000
kilocalories, 10% of that,
we'd be talking about approximately
800 potential kilocalories
per square meter per year
that'd be available for the next layer.
Now you might be saying, "Hey,
where are all of the
other calories going?"
Well, remember, even in this first layer,
we said this is net primary production.
The gross would be even higher.
These photosynthesizers had
to use that energy for things
like respiration, and
even on the net basis,
the reason why so much
gets lost when you go
to the next layer, is these animals here.
They have to use that energy to live,
to do things like respiration
and a lot of this energy is
just not consumable by the next layer.
So it can become detritus, which is,
you can just think of this biomass
that is just laying around.
Energy at every level can be lost to heat,
can be used for movement, for growth.
So you can imagine you
get to a level above that,
we could call this secondary consumer.
And this is just a picture of a grouper.
Marine ecosystems would be
much more complex than this,
but the net calories after
the groupers lived their life,
et cetera, et cetera, that
is available to the level
above that would be roughly, again, 10%.
So maybe 80 kilocalories
per square meter per year.
And that at least in this example,
at the top of this pyramid,
we have an apex predator, that is a shark.
What is available after
the shark's done all
of its business is roughly 10% of that.
So approximately eight kilocalories
per square meter per year.
And so the important
thing to think about is,
whether we're talking about terrestrial
or marine environments,
you have this significant
loss of energy as we go
from one layer of the pyramid to another,
but at the same time, everyone
has to be using energy.
And the energy has to come from someplace
and we've covered in other videos,
it's coming from sunlight.
And there has to be this continual process
of taking light energy and
through photosynthesis converting
it into a form of energy
that can be used by life.
And then you have significant energy loss,
but that energy keeps
flowing up this pyramid.
And we're not even done because
even the apex predators,
at some point they're going to die
and then they have tissue
and in that biomass
there's energy that could
be consumed by others.
Also to release nutrients
that could be used
by these initial primary producers.
And that's where things like detritivores,
and this is a starfish,
which is a detritivore,
things that can actually
consume dead matter.
They are really useful because
then they can bring nutrients
back to primary producers, and to others.
And when we're talking
about an aquatic environment
like this and we're talking
about photosynthesis,
one question you might be asking is,
"Wait, where can photosynthesis occur?
If you go deep enough it's
going to get quite dark."
And you'd be right if you
were asking that question.
When you think about marine environments,
there's something known
as a euphotic zone,
which is the zone where
it's shallow enough
to get enough light
so that you can actually
do photosynthesis.
And so it's no coincidence
that things like estuaries,
things where the water is shallower,
where there's going to be more nutrients
and where there's going to be more light,
that you actually have
more primary production.